Ngày Mui Tạng 5, Hẵn Thuyền Rồi Tơ giận thủ báo từ diện Kremlin Chuyết, ngài đặt tì vọng giất lớn và chuyên thăm Trung Quốc của tổng thống Vladimir Putin trong tôn này.
Người phân ngôn diện Kremlin Dimitriy Paskov nhảm ảnh, Hà Ben sẽ tìt đủ phát triển quan hệ đối tái trín lộn mang tình tập biệt.
Theo kế hoạch, tổng thống Putin sẽ thăm Trung Quốc trong hà ngài Mỹ-Chín và Hà Mui Tạng 5, chính ngày dưới chuyên thăm của tổng thống Mỹ đuôn nân trong tối bắc kinh.
Điện Kremlin Chuyết, đe là dị quan trọng để cùng của quan hệ đối tác đặc quyền giãi nữa.
Phà đòn ngài thăm sự chuyên thăm lần này sẽ bác của nhiều phó thu tổng bộ trường và lãnh đạo xong nghiệp lớn.
Một trong những nổi giung được quan tâm là hợp tám ngược.
Trong đó, có sự ăn đường ở Khi Đốt Power of Siberia 2, dự kiến phần chuyển thêm lượng lượng khi đó tự 2 sang Trung Quốc qua mong câu.
Tuy nhiên, Điện Kremlin Chuyết, các bạn đe của thay vấn nằm trong truy trình nghị sử và sẽ được thảo luận giãi Ben.
Dởi qua sang nhận định, chuyến thăm sinh xa Trung Quốc cảnh cảnh trị trị lượng giờ các cửa tế tục giả tăng,
Chúng khi Más, các bạn và Mát Tinh đều nhấn mạnh một tiêu suy chiều định và mở giọng hợp tám xong phương trên nhiều lĩnh vâng.